- Season four, Worth It.
- It's gonna be on the internet.
- That's right.
- Uh, yeah.
8:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time.
12 episodes this time
around for season four,
so, you know...
Yeah, March 18th.
It's gonna be a fun time.
- Turn on the trailer right now.
- Season four, huh?
How did we get here?
♪ Whoa oh ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
- Here's to season four.
- Woo hoo hoo.
We're going to a special place next.
Road trip!
Sky trip!
Home trip!
- Some people aspire to own luxury cars.
I want to pay a premium to get
that hand crank meat slicer.
- Can I get some of that?
No, uh.
(laughs)
- [Andrew] I love seeing food get made.
You start salivating in anticipation.
- It's the preview for the movies.
- [Chef] In Korea, mommy, grandma
always make food with their hands.
That's what I'm doing,
with love, you know?
- This is actually the first
full service vegan restaurant
in the history of Harlem.
- [Woman] We wanted to make a
difference in the community.
It seems to be a hit,
'cause everybody loves it.
- Whoa!
- I've kind of developed a diet of a bear,
force feeding every day
and then I go to sleep for six months,
and then I do it again
and that is the Worth It season.
- [Man] Oh, yes!